welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and disney plus has finally
released a series of marvel one shots
these are short films produced in
earlier mcu eras to follow characters in
between film events connect the dots and
give spotlights to those weirdos on the
wings these include the consultant in
which shield agents coulson and sitwell
conspired to get hulk on the avengers
instead of abomination released on the
thor blu-ray in 2011. a funny thing
happened on the way to thor's hammer in
which coulson stops a robbery released
on the blu-ray for the first cap film in
2011 item 47 in which sitwell tracks
down a loose shitari weapon after the
battle of new york released on the
avengers blu ray in 2012 agent carter in
which peggy carter deals with her a-hole
boss while recovering the zodiac serum
released on the iron man 3 blu-ray in
2013 and led to agent carter getting
their own two-season series all hail the
king follows trevor slattery after iron
man 3 getting taken from prison by the
10 rings setting up his eventual return
in chongqi originally released on the
thor of the dark world blu-ray in 2014
and then team thor parts one and two and
team daryl mockumentaries directed by
taiko aditi following thor and his
roommate daryl released in 2016 on the
civil war blu-ray 2017 on the doctor
strange blu-ray and in 2018 on the
ragnarok blu-ray i love re-watching
these because they are technically mcu
canon and based on recent marvel titles
kevin feige seems super intent on
bringing elements from these shorts back
to build a future of the mcu so in this
video i am going to break down the first
two of these to try to figure out is
agent coulson coming back to the mcu and
after the netflix marvel crossovers in
spider-man no way home and in hawkeye
could marvel studios also be secretly
planning to officially restore agents of
shield as mcu cannon as it remains in
the minds of the fans so let's start
with the consultant this short takes
place during fury's big week in which
the events of iron man 2 thor the
incredible hulk and the modern day
events of the first cap film all go down
in the same week from shield's
perspective phil coulson meets with
jasper sitwell who sips a dr pepper mug
and asks coulson about the world
security council's intentions for the
avengers i want blotsky on the team the
abomination they really don't like when
you call it that but the harlem is in it
they're pinning that on banner on banner
not the guy you want to make angry
they consider blonsky a war hero they
want it exonerated released and then
added to the roster emil blonsky played
by tim roth was a super soldier enhanced
with a similar serum from the us
military's attempts to recreate dr
abraham erskine's serum used to make
captain america blonsky engaged hulk at
culver university and then juiced up
again on a serum from banner's gamma
irradiated blood to become abomination
leading to a rumble in harlem now to
everyone's surprise this guy returned in
chiang chi redesigned to his comic
accurate appearance with tim roth
recording audio for the cameo now he's a
sparring partner to wang and macau's
golden daggers club run by xiling now we
still don't know for sure the nature of
abomination in wong's relationship but
no way home confirmed that wang is
currently sorcerer's supreme and he may
have a side deal with thaddeus ross to
train ross's assets to form a new lineup
that may become the mcu's thunderbolts
or dark avengers but back in this short
coulson then asks sitwell about his
clearance level what's your clearance
level
it's funny it's level six
like you
come on there's a level seven now
remember sit well at this point is
totally a hydra operative so his
frustration of feeling out of the loop
has a deeper context to it in agents of
shield coulson would later go on to
become level 8 clearance and then level
blue when they switch to the color
system but coulson then says that
blonsky is being kept in ross's sector
and that they plan to send a patsy to
ross to bungle the debriefing so badly
that ross wouldn't want to give them
abomination anymore i could do it
i do a great patsy i'm thinking for this
we need a slightly different skill set
if we want the general to refuse this
request then we have to send someone who
will truly annoy him
someone arrogant and abrasive with an
utter disdain for authority someone who
will offend the general to his very core
you're talking about the conditions
now again it's interesting that sitwell
volunteers here one wonders what this
hydra mole hoped to gain from chatting
with ross maybe to have abomination
transfer to a facility operated by other
hydro loyalists like senator stern and
this leads us to the scene that we
actually saw at the end of the 2008
incredible hulk film you know i hate to
say a told you so general but that super
soldier program was put on ice for a
reason
i've always felt that hardware was much
more reliable you always wear such nice
suits i hear you have an unusual problem
you should talk
you should listen so now that moment is
redefined as less of a random flirtation
by tony stark who did later on seem
super reluctant to join nick fury's
super secret boy band and instead make
this more of a maneuver by shield to use
that stark wild card to swap abomination
for hulk but again this is really as
much of a maneuver by hydra because it
looks like val is ultimately part of
ross's dark avenger recruitment
operation and we are still waiting to
find out where her loyalties lie and
what incarnation of herself she will be
from the comics madame hydra a skrull
plant a victoria hand equivalent now we
did see victoria hand in agents of
shield but hold that thought as we move
on to the second one-shot short film a
funny thing happened on the way to
thor's hammer a tile inspired by stephen
sondheim's musical a funny thing
happened on the way to the forum this is
also set during fury's big week right
after coulson left tony stark and iron
man 2. i've been reassigned
director fury wants me in new mexico
fantastic land of enchantment so i'm
told secret stuff something like that
and before he arrived to find that
mjolnir crater in the post-credits scene
here he drives the desert road 473 miles
out from puente antiguo a fictional town
with its name translating to ancient
bridge reflecting this location's role
as an access point for midgard using the
ancient bifrost bridge coulson stops at
a roxon gas station and uses roxon
premium roxon being the energy
conglomerate of the mcu which recently
showed up in loki as the owner of rox
cart and the whole doomed town of haven
hills alabama colson your use of a
fossil fuel burning car instead of your
arc reactor-powered lola contributed to
that cat 8 hurricane now folks to be
honest i stayed up super late finishing
this video i wanted to sleep in but it's
not always easy to do that i got a lot
of lights in my room surge protector
lights lights on my devices alarm clocks
that glowing ghostly orb that always
floats over my face well that is where
the blue blocks remedy sleep masks comes
in handy we do blue blocks from their
blue light blocking glasses but their
sleep mask goes further and blocks out
100 of light for better sleep it's
really soft and has these adjustable eye
cups an adjustable strap for the perfect
fit it works for belly sleepers side
sleepers back sleepers and this sleeper
uh i can't see anything is the world
still there my reality is based on my
perception they're made from a
breathable material and you can fully
open your eyes while wearing it like
cyclops with his ruby quartz glasses
except you know no optic blasts it's
great for improving your sleep your
meditation napping travel i love using
it when i want to sleep or just grab a
nap during the day they ship worldwide
and have other great products like red
light therapy devices so go to
blueblocks.com new rockstars and use the
coupon code new rockstars to save twenty
percent that's
blueblox.com b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com slash new rockstars and use
coupon code new rockstars to save 20 but
inside as coulson tries to decide
between powdered donuts and chocolate
covered ones two armed robbers stick up
the cashier and coulson reveals himself
and tosses over his keys i also have
this gun you'll probably be needing that
put it down put it right now okay don't
want any trouble
toss the piece over here then i'd prefer
not to throw it and risk the gun
accidentally going off
maybe i could slide it over yeah really
smart camera direction and some smart
negotiating tactics by coulson after
seeing the robbers in the mirror he
surprises them but gently trying to get
them to point their guns away from the
cashier then he steps over to the side
aisle where the gunman on the right
would be more in the blind when he would
throw the bag of flour at him giving
himself the drop ultimately on both
gunmen
[Applause]
[Music]
in an interesting bit of vfx here when
coulson kicks the gunman's shotgun
downward the shot spray seems to only
blast up pieces of floor tile but the
gun was pointed directly at the gunman's
foot and he screams in pain i think the
original version of this had coulson
redirecting the gun so that the guy
would shoot his freaking foot off
spraying blood all over this floor but
they changed into the effects so that
just a bit of tile dust got on his foot
no blood visible so where does this
leave coulson's fate in the mcu well
coulson died in the 2012 avengers film a
death that proved crucial to rallying
the avengers together to defeat loki's
forces however unbeknownst to them
coulson was resurrected by nick fury
using a process called tahiti cree
medical technology that reanimates the
brain and wipes away certain memories an
advanced version of this was used on
carol danvers and captain marvel
transfusing yon rogg's cree blood into
her body after they took her and
reprogrammed her it's my blood
that's coursing through her veins now in
later seasons of agents of shield
coulson gets swapped out for a life
model decoy lmds these come from the
comics and were hinted at in the first
avengers film interestingly enough to
coulson directly you have reached the
life model decoy of tony stark please
leave a message now the character of
phil coulson was brought back into the
mcu in the captain marvel film but only
in the event set back in 1995 before his
death his current status in the mcu
present is unconfirmed various
statements over the years have had fans
debating over agents of shield's true
canonicity joss whedon said his
intention for the 2012 avengers and age
of ultron was that coulson remained dead
in the movies just not on the show
suggesting that agents of shield existed
in a kind of side universe but according
to twitter these days those movies were
now actually directed by either kevin
feige or ray fisher i don't know don't
ask me how dr strange's spell worked
agents of shield's later seasons moved
away from trying to connect to the mcu
so much using time travel to bypass the
events of infinity war and in-game but
then in agents of shield's final season
they actually used endgame same exact
quantum realm timeline mechanics to tie
everything back together fitz did just
the right branch timeline arm dancing to
logically justify agents of shield as an
alternate timeline within the mcu's vast
array of alternate histories which the
loki series either clarified or made
more confusing with implications that
variant loki's like silvi kid loki gator
loki all came from alternate universes
and agents of shield's final shot
included the shield triskelion building
in the dc skyline meaning that this must
be a side reality where it was not
destroyed compared to its destroyed
status in the mcu now recently some
agents of shield fans worried that the
reveal in hawkeye that laura barton was
agent 19 erased or retconned bobby
morse's mockingbird and agents of shield
but i would argue many people could have
just carried the agent 19 designation
over the years now agents of shield also
brought back the character of susa
originally from agent carter and that
series technically has a stronger
argument for canonicity since james
darcy appeared in avengers end game as
edwin jarvis a character originally
introduced on agent carter making him
the first and so far only character
introduced first in either agent carter
agents of shield to appear in an mcu
film however that may be changing the
agent carter one shot short film
introduced bradley whitford as agent
john flynn of the strategic scientific
reserve and marvel brought whitford back
to voice flynn on what if what if is
technically mcu canon right now and
rumors are suggesting that marvel might
have some plans to bring back hayley
outwell as captain carter in live action
meaning other elements from her agents
of shield connected world could also
return for years we suspected that kevin
feige's hesitancy to embrace agents of
shield as official mcu cannon came from
the fact that it was a production under
a different division of marvel
entertainment overseen not by him but
the same was also true for the netflix
marvel corner of the universe which once
occupied a similar canon vagueness as
agents of shield did referencing mcu
events but never itself getting
referenced in the mcu and that all
changed spectacularly with spider-man no
way home featuring charlie cox as matt
murdock daredevil and hawkeye featuring
vincent d'onofrio as wilson fisk kingpin
both from the previously separate
netflix marvel continuity and unlike the
multiversal cameos of green goblin.gog
other spider-man variants in that movie
daredevil and kingpin are now just
suggested to have already existed in mcu
history so this just goes to show you
how simple it would really be for kevin
feige and his team to clear up any
confusion over what is and isn't mcu
canon going forward for daredevil and
kingpin there is some historical
muddiness if you go digging too deep in
those netflix episodes but for coulson
and the agents of shield characters the
logic is all right there for marvel
studios to endorse take credit for build
on and profit from and there are a few
ways marvel could do this they could
fold coulson's return into a coming
multiverse reset and doctor strange and
multiverse of madness like suggest sure
isn't a shield ended in a side universe
but things from that universe are now
merged into this one thanks so wanda
coulson could also come back as a skrull
and secret invasion now yes when coulson
died in 2012 he did not revert to scroll
form so that wasn't a scroll imposter he
was already impersonated by a squirrel
once in captain marvel but again it
doesn't have to be that complicated with
project tahiti and the life model decoys
agents of shield already gave us plenty
of ways coulson could still be alive
that doesn't negate any of the mcu film
continuity and now on disney plus thanks
to these marvel one shots new fans are
discovering just how fun clark gregg was
to watch in this universe so let's hope
his marvel one shots being added to the
disney plus page of mcu titles will
really precede all of agents of shield
being added as well and when the dust
settles after multiverse of madness may
it also end with lmd coulson running a
still intact shield clearance level
platinum parking lola in his private
garage on the triskelion as abigail
brand and nick fury conference call in
from the peak space station with some
nonsense about scrolls just for colson
to respond you have reached the life
model decoy of director phil coulson
please leave a message you can support
new rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow new rockstars and subscribe and
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching colson
[Music]
you